[Music]
my father came to your beautiful country
when i was a child
he had heard about the mythical
vibranium
but
the black panther said
they had no vibranium to give
he slit my father's throat
that panther
is dead
so you will have to do
you
and your people
[Music]
you finally agreed to accept help and it
is from outsiders
that is not like you
i am not accepting help
i am giving it
then let me send teams to the corrupted
sites
take the dora milaje with you do
something other than driving yourself
head fast into danger i am not just a
king on a throne
i am the black panther
then show us you can be both
i will
finish the job boys
[Music]
can you try not to belong
you should impress your spiritual side
[Music]
got a couple toys just for you
here's my call
with me
we
[Music]
the whole place is coming down
[Music]
welcome to the war table for wakanda a
walkthrough of the new expansion
starring black panther coming to
marvel's avengers tomorrow at no
additional cost
warfare wakanda is an exciting new
release that aims at refreshing the
marvel's avengers experience and is the
largest and most ambitious expansion
since launch we're excited to welcome
black panther to marvel's avengers and
today we're going to share details with
you about the story campaign new
gameplay enemies and more
and of course we couldn't bring the king
to avengers without also bringing his
kingdom so we'll be unveiling some new
details and footage of wakanda as well
to ensure our war for wakanda story does
justice to such an important hero our
narrative team enlisted the help of
well-known writer and black panther
expert evan narciss author of the rise
of the black panther marvel comics
[Music]
from the very first meeting the team had
with evan they felt a special magic and
are really proud of the work they've
done to craft an original story and
bring black panther to life
together they threw themselves into the
challenge of both respecting and
celebrating existing black panther
stories and bringing the culture of
wakanda to life here's evan to tell you
more about himself
hi everybody it's evan narciss i'm here
of course to talk about the war for
wakanda expansion for marvel's avengers
when we were working on the war for
wakanda story the narrative team and i
drew inspiration from so many different
story arcs in the comics dating back to
the black panther storylines such as who
was the black panther by reginald hudlin
and john reiter jr and a nation under
her feet by tan ozzy coates and brian
stelfries
so these stories were of course so
important to how we thought about our
version of the black panther when we
were working on the narrative for
warfare wakanda it was essential for us
to tell a wakandan story even though it
takes place in the avengers universe and
of course wakanda is its own sovereign
african nation it's also the most
advanced civilization on earth
its technological achievement is fueled
by vibranium a precious material found
only in a meteor that crashed on earth
centuries ago
the kingdom is ruled by king t'challa
the black panther and in warfare wakanda
t'challa faces a massive invasion unlike
anything the country has ever faced
before t'challa is a man who lives many
roles he's a king he's a leader of
entire nation and he's a brother
and this invasion will test him in all
of those roles it's gonna be really
difficult for him to figure out who he
is and what he needs to be for wakanda
to be safe this invasion is led by
ulysses claw a rogue scientist with a
dark secret and a darker grudge
claus assembled an army of mercenaries
all of them equipped with deadly sonic
technology and large spider-like mechs
that he unleashes into the wakanda
jungle claw is being bankrolled by one
of the world's most sinister
organizations and he uses all that money
and all those resources to plant sonic
fracking towers all over wakanda so he
can extract vibranium from the soil
this is a devastating process that
corrupts the vibranium and creates
clusters of deadly poisonous shards that
show up all over the world
this of course is how the avengers get
involved in the war for wakanda
after the 8 a disaster wakanda closed
its borders and cut off all
communication with the outside world
after the dangerous corrupted vibranium
starts to appear all over the globe the
avengers travel to wakanda to offer
their help to king t'challa another
important character showing up in the
expansion is okoye she's the captain of
the dora milage an elite fighting force
that answers only to the king she's also
kind of the voice of truth for t'challa
which means she tells the king stuff
that everybody else is afraid to even
voice
along with the koi we've got zavavari
he's a mystic who has this really tense
fraught relationship with the royal
family
t'challa is not the only member of the
royal family showing up in this
expansion we also have his younger
sister princess shuri she's the head of
technological development in wakanda
she doesn't agree with the child's
approach to dealing with claw and the
war for wakanda expansion exposes the
fragility of t'challa and shuri's
relationship
it sets up a series of confrontations
that will test their bond as well as
their partnership with the avengers even
if they all find a way to come together
it may not be enough to stop the growing
threat to wakanda and its people
the narrative team and i we created this
new original black panther adventure
drawing on inspiration from so many
amazing existing story lines from the
comics and other iterations of the
character we all know and love this
character so much and want to share that
love with all of you guys and we're so
excited about bringing this new
adventure to marvel's avengers for all
of you to enjoy
[Music]
black panther is known for his cat-like
agility and lethal claws he is an
untouchable force that can pounce at any
moment the team has crafted a full
arsenal of custom moves to capture his
fighting style and bring him to life
out of my sight is black panther's
signature attack which can be charged
with intrinsic energy to perform the
kinetic slash a spiraling uppercut
from this move black panther can branch
in and out of the spinning strike light
combo
pounce from the ground or the air to
grab enemies and unleash a flurry of
claw strikes the intrinsic meter is
super important for black panther you're
going to want to prioritize blocking and
parrying to store kinetic energy which
can then be released in a percussive
blast
black panther's percussive blast
unleashes all your stored energy in a
large kinetic burst that knocks away
nearby enemies and boosts black panthers
melee damage for a short time
perform a parry just before an enemy
attack connects to turn their attack
into a blast of kinetic energy that
knocks them back and staggers nearby
foes
enemies who have recently been parried
are easier to interrupt with attacks
black panther can construct daggers made
of energy and vibranium which can be
thrown at enemies near or far his basic
daggers will embed into targets making
them more vulnerable to melee damage
they're a great way to weaken an enemy
before unleashing a barrage of melee
attacks
the kimoyo beads can target enemies or
allies and provide either detrimental or
restorative abilities to their target
the beads can be upgraded and provide
additional support or offensive
capabilities such as armor against
attacks destroying incoming projectiles
shooting enemy targets or dealing damage
over time additional skills can be
unlocked to supercharge your sprint
evade signature and combo finisher
attacks using your intrinsic energy
there are so many ways to play black
panther but here are some powerful
highlights
the assault rulic king's mercy is a
vibranium spear that can pin multiple
targets and deal out large amounts of
damage the sphere can be customized to
explode on contact or create multiple
smaller spheres for rapid fire call upon
the power of the panther goddess bast to
summon a spectral panther to charge
through your foes and empower black
panther with the energy from the
ancestral plane boosting defensive
capabilities unleash supercharged
attacks without expending any intrinsic
energy the ultimate can be customized to
revive down heroes weaken at nearby
enemies and even summon spectral
warriors to fight alongside
black panther himself is a fully unique
hero with the same amount of skills and
gear as the rest of the avengers he'll
have around 40 outfits and a full suite
of emotes takedowns and nameplates for
the marketplace
releasing alongside the war for wakanda
expansion is an extensive refresh to the
menu pages for marvel's avengers
some of the biggest updates are related
to the new unified character page it
contains everything associated with a
hero in one easy-to-navigate space here
you can manage your gear cosmetics
emotes and takedowns as well as view
hero and challenge card progress so you
can get back to the action more quickly
this update includes commonly requested
improvements for managing a hero's
loadout including more easily comparing
items locking your favorite gear for
safety and dismantling multiple items at
once direct access to your locker from
anywhere adds an extra layer of
convenience
this only scratches the surface of ui
improvements our team has crafted for
you in this update
as evan mentioned earlier we have drawn
a lot of inspiration from the black
panther comics while striving to make a
unique and respectful rendition of
wakanda and its cast of characters
war for wakanda features a full new
biome the jungles of wakanda showing off
both the rich and amazing history of
this ancient unconquered african country
but also the futuristic symbiotic
technology of contemporary wakanda at
the center is the wakandan capital zanna
where our new outpost is located
it features king t'challa's throne room
from where he rules and the command
center where all important decisions
regarding the country's security takes
place
shuri's lab houses the nerve center for
wakanda's kimoyo network
the spiritual annex is located on the
lower floor where zavavari aids the
royal family in the ways of mystical
powers
the wakanda mission design is built on
the same foundation as marvel's avengers
but with new objectives and an extra
focus on dangerous traversal exploration
and puzzles
almost all warfare wakanda content is
multiplayer enabled apart from the
introduction mission which is single
player only this is where black panther
is introduced and celebrated as a new
unique hero
[Music]
warfare wakanda features a full a-list
cast of actors helmed by christopher
judge as black panther christopher is
best known for playing kratos in the
latest god of war game and from the tv
show stargate shuri is played by erica
latrell known from dishonored westworld
and apex legends okoye is played by
deborah wilson from star wars jedi
fallen order and zavavari is played by
dave fennoy best known from the walking
dead games steve bloom is going all in
as the villain ulysses claw
to get the wakandan accent just right we
worked closely with beth maguire the
dialect coach from the black panther
movie
beth has had multiple coaching sessions
with each of the key actors to ensure
that the accents are properly delivered
and has been an integral part of the
voice sessions
[Music]
as you may have already noticed wakanda
will release with several new enemies
the main villain is black panther's
nemesis from the comics ulysses claw
also known simply as claw and we're
bringing a new sonic rendition of him to
life based on his iconic marvel look
claw's story is linked to wakanda and
we're excited to reveal our all-new
version of his origins in this expansion
claw has brought with him a team of
mercenaries they have a variety of
vibranium and sonic powered weapons and
should pose a real challenge for black
panther and the avengers
we're also introducing a new menace the
spider-like crawlers they come in
different variants including smaller
sized scout crawlers and large hunter
crawlers we're excited to announce the
legendary comic villain crossbones as
claws head lieutenant and to debut
wakanda with two new villains in one
expansion crossbones or brock rumlow is
a sociopathic super mercenary who works
for the highest bidder and he's ready to
lead the invasion of wakanda crossbones
is a formidable foe and has an
impressive arsenal at his disposal
including an impenetrable shield that
makes him immune to many of black
panther's attacks
discover crossbones origins and find out
how the avengers created their own enemy
thank you for joining us for our war for
wakanda war table log in tomorrow to
play black panther and defend wakanda
alongside the avengers here's one last
look at how massive marvel's avengers
has become and why now is the right time
to assemble
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
i'm standing in wakanda
i still can't believe it
[Music]
you